on this saturday night russia ratchets
up its assault on ukraine
what moscow's hypersonic missiles are
capable of and what putin may be hoping
to accomplish
i don't think it'll work
fresh bombardments decimating buildings
in ukraine
as people wait for their worst fears to
become a reality and the supply chain is
choked off
up in flames the deadly inferno that
destroyed an entire texas town and who
helped develop hockey it needs to be
brought to the canadian public's
attention the game plan to give credit
where credit is due
global national reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us
russian forces are pushing further into
the besieged and battered city of
mariopol tonight where fierce fighting
has erupted in the city's center
this was once a school a place of peace
and learning not anymore waves of
russian airstrikes have bombarded the
city for weeks civilians say they can't
even bury the dead as fighting rages on
there are fears mariopol will fall in
the days ahead if it does it'll be the
first major ukrainian city to be seized
providing a strategic advantage to
russian forces russia is slowly
advancing on multiple fronts and now for
the first time since the invasion
russian-fired hypersonic missiles have
killed dozens of soldiers and destroyed
a military ammunitions warehouse in
mykolave a port city near the black sea
our mercedes stephenson is in la viv
with the latest and mercedes is this a
sign russia has escalated the war
calling hypersonic missiles are a weapon
that could change the face of modern
warfare and we now know that russia is
actively using these weapons in ukraine
in combat for the first time a claim
initially made by the russians and
verified by american officials to a u.s
news network
in a briefing on saturday the russian
defense ministry revealed it used the
hypersonic kinzhal missile system
claiming a strike destroyed an
underground arms depot of missiles and
aircraft ammunition in the town of de la
tin located about a hundred kilometers
from the border with romania the
destruction of the depot could not be
confirmed hypersonic missiles are a new
kind of threat ballistic missiles that
move extraordinarily fast at least five
times the speed of sound a flash of
light and destruction their extreme
speed precision and maneuverability even
mid-flight means they are highly
effective at striking targets and
difficult to defend against with
existing air defense systems
that's made them desirable weapons in a
global arms race for countries like the
u.s china and russia seeking to shorten
the time adversaries have to react to a
potential strike and increasing their
accuracy
the kinjal missile used in ukraine means
dagger in russian
it was first introduced by vladimir
putin in 2018 to showcase moscow's
military superiority as recently as last
december putin was again bragging about
russia's hypersonic capabilities calling
them world-leading
russia claims the missile system can
travel at mach 10 that's ten times the
speed of sound or twelve thousand
kilometers an hour these claims have not
been independently verified
the russian missile system has a range
of one to two thousand kilometers but
that can be extended because they're
fired by military jets
while there's no doubt that the use of a
hypersonic missile is a show stopper
experts say it's also likely showmanship
as much a psychological weapon as a
tactical one putin's war in ukraine has
been struggling and experts say he
likely wants to show a message to the
west about his military strength and
capabilities the dangers that putin
the sociopath may well try to use other
weapon systems to try and uh club
the ukraine defenders into submission i
don't think it will work
but uh you and i don't think the same
way that he does
here in la vie where missiles struck
yesterday life continues and while
there's live music and crammed cafes
there's also soldiers in the streets
with guns and air raid sirens as the
people of ukraine wait to see how
vladimir putin will continue to escalate
in his weapons and his targets colleen
mercedes stephenson in la viv ukraine
thanks mercedes russian forces are
surrounding cities crippling
humanitarian supply chains and escape
routes in what appears to be a new and
disturbing tactic of slowly starving
civilians tonight our jeff semple is
near odessa ukraine where food and water
are running out
in normal times the odessa food market
serves an eclectic mix of seafood pasta
and pints but these are not normal times
today volunteers are collecting and
dishing out medicine blankets and other
life-saving supplies to civilians and
soldiers fighting on the front line
which is only about 100 kilometers from
here
we have a little gap of time to prepare
our city before the war inga kordenovska
ran a law firm now she runs a
humanitarian volunteer center with most
businesses closed they're providing food
for thousands but three weeks into the
war supplies are already running out we
don't have russian occupation in the
city but it's really difficult to find
some very necessary things especially
medicines russia's push into parts of
ukraine appears to have stalled but its
military is choking ukraine's supply
chains according to the country's
president
appearing in another defiant video
vladimir zelinski said russia is trying
to starve civilians into submission the
stark choice now facing ordinary
ukrainians stay and risk dying from
fighting or starvation or leave but for
some that cost is also unbearable this
has fast become a heart-wrenching
routine since the invasion regular rail
service is suspended but every day these
free trains arrive to take women and
children who want to leave out of the
country anna and her eight-year-old
daughter came to catch a train to poland
even though it means leaving her husband
and her mother behind
yesterday
we couldn't wait any longer we have to
go where there's still an opportunity
but we're leaving with a heavy heart she
says ukrainian men are required to stay
behind and fight this crowd is full of
families who may be seeing each other
for the last time as the train arrives
there's a scramble to get on board to
secure a spot leaving no time for a
proper goodbye
many like anna's husband linger outside
the window as long as they can savoring
every last moment before the train
carrying their wives and children pulls
away
but many residents of odessa remain
trying to carry on even as russian
forces inch closer
we are doing our best trying to live a
normal life he says on a sunny saturday
the city's main market was packed
odessa's largest jazz club is closed
because of the war so the musicians
performed from the balcony people need
some bright light during all this stuff
russia has more soldiers a much bigger
military but ukraine's spirit feels
insurmountable
jeff semple global news odessa
more than 3 million people have fled the
war in ukraine and that number is
growing mike armstrong has more on why
leaving or staying are both risky
options
these are images released by an aide to
the ukrainian president they are
refugees being picked up from two cities
in the central part of the country and
taken to safer areas of the 10
humanitarian corridors open on this day
two led to the city of bravery just east
of keefe
stories from that city's hospital help
explain the challenge and the danger of
trying to get around this man was shot
three times
he says he's a civilian and was
traveling in a civilian vehicle russian
soldiers he says shot through his
windshield
if moving is dangerous so is staying put
in a place like mariupol right now it
means more misery every day
this woman just escaped
this woman says she spent 10 days in a
cellar hiding from bombs and didn't
leave once they had no electricity and
no running water
in the town of zaparica a grocery store
is turned into a refugee center many of
the people in it left mariupol and
consider themselves lucky the macbool
this man says anyone who could leave did
but many didn't make it they drove by
bombed and burned out cars on their way
out of town there were bodies he says in
the streets
now this is where so many want to go
west to poland of the more than 3.2
million refugees who fled ukraine about
two-thirds have crossed into poland
this mother of five says by the time she
decided to leave her home west of keeve
with her children there was no food and
no way to stay
on this day among those crossing over
was a woman whose destination is canada
she'd been on vacation was home in
ukraine visiting her parents from
studying sociology in canada when the
war broke out she didn't regret being
there actually i'm kind of really glad
that i could go here even though it's
like it's real terrible right now but at
least i could see my parents because i
don't know it's going to be she says
right now her future is hard to worry
about she's safe in poland her thoughts
are all about her parents who stayed
behind
mike armstrong global news jeshof poland
as thousands continue to escape ukraine
many will make their way to canada but
just how ready is ottawa to handle the
influx of newcomers and how long will
they receive federal assistance our
chief political correspondent david
aiken sat down with canada's immigration
minister to get some answers david since
january the first canada has taken in
more than 9 200 ukrainians including
more than 3 300 since the russian
invasion began on february 24th but with
the total number of ukrainians fleeing
their war-ravaged country totaling well
over 3 million already
canada is expecting that many more will
seek refuge behind our borders how many
more immigration minister sean frazier
says that's impossible to say it's hard
to predict the precise number that we
should plan for and that's why we built
a program that was designed to respond
to demand rather than a predetermined
allocation as we do with ordinary
refugee resettlement programs which are
typically spread
over many years
canada took in for example more than 73
thousand syrian refugees it has set a
goal of resettling 40 000 afghanistan
refugees of which 9 000 are already here
but while refugees from syria and
afghanistan who build new lives in
canada do not expect to return to their
country of origin the hope and the
expectation is that ukrainians coming to
canada will return once war ends with
respect to the crisis in ukraine we
needed to build a system that had that
flexibility to respond to the short-term
demand but the supports that are needed
may vary greatly and there is one other
key difference most of the refugees are
women and children ukrainian law has
made it illegal for fighting age men to
leave that country and that means the
supports canada will provide those women
and children who hope to be here only
for a year maybe two
will have to be different than the
support systems of our other refugee
resettlement programs which are
typically aimed at families who plan to
permanently stay in canada colleen
thanks david and david's hosting the
west block this week you can watch his
full interview with the immigration
minister tomorrow right here on global
together russia and ukraine are
responsible for more than a quarter of
the world's wheat exports now as the war
stretches into its fourth week
implications for the global food supply
are becoming all too clear with some
warning the consequences could be
catastrophic dan spector has that part
of the story
this tranquil farm in france's
countryside is thousands of kilometers
from the destruction in ukraine but
isabel le baler says collateral damage
from the conflict is being felt here on
her green pastures very direct today
there is a direct impact on our farm she
says her animals eat grain and le baler
says the price per ton has more than
doubled since the war began not to
mention the sharp rise in the cost of
fuel and her inability to sell her
animals for more an equation she
describes as unbearable
kobit 19 labor shortages and inflation
have already contributed to a rise in
food prices and now a region often
called europe's bread basket is in chaos
together russia and ukraine account for
nearly 30 percent of the globe's wheat
and that's not all the three f's all are
impacted very highly food fertilizers
are fueled the longer the conflict rages
on the higher the chance of food
shortages it will have a very very big
impact on a lot of asian and african
countries directly but throughout the
world indirectly in some way crippling
sanctions on russia have reduced supply
and on saturday poland's prime minister
proposed europe block all trade with
moscow
fully cutting off russia's trade would
further force russia to consider whether
it would be better to stop this cruel
war he said if there is something like
that full uh trade blockade
it will have a very severe impact could
canada increase its wheat production to
help fill the void right now that
question is difficult to answer you know
last year we had a pretty bad drought
the most recent crop was short by about
7 million tons farmers are hoping for
better weather but there's also a seed
shortage rising costs and a need to
rotate crops even if we produce
even the normal
amount of wheat that might still not be
enough to meet the global demand adding
yet another twist there's a looming work
stoppage at cp rail trains are vital for
wheat producers to get their products to
market 3 000 workers could be locked out
early sunday if an agreement is not met
daya says canada's reputation is at risk
dan spector global news ottawa
a 24 year old man has been arrested for
allegedly attacking worshipers with bear
spray inside a mosque near toronto
police say he was also waving a hatchet
several men held him until officers
arrived investigators are considering
all possible motivations including hate
coming up the out-of-control wildfire in
texas that's already came to life and
burned a town to the ground
raging wildfires in texas have now
turned deadly a sheriff's deputy was
killed trying to save others officials
are sifting through the destruction as
crews tried to gain the upper hand
during a break in the weather jennifer
johnson reports
it's a race against time for texas
firefighters as gusty winds are
predicted to return sunday the
wind-fueled wildfires have already
scorched hundreds of kilometers
destroying almost the entire town of
ranger i've been fire chief here 40
years and
and when you have something like this it
hurts it hurts the whole community the
largest wildfire is burning in east sun
county surrounded by thick brush and
grassy areas hundreds of homes there
have been evacuated one sheriff's deputy
sergeant barbara finley was going door
to door telling people to get out but
lost her life after returning to check
on an elderly resident she was out
serving trying to evacuate people and
just
tragedy struck
and but she's going to be missed so much
fenley leaves behind a husband and three
children the governor of texas paid his
respects to the first responder later
declaring 11 counties a disaster already
we know that there have been at least
50 homes that have been lost
probably as we are able to better
surveil
damages here in the coming days we will
find more than that the smoke is so
heavy air quality warnings have been
issued in houston five hours away
several months of dry windy weather have
fueled deadly fires in kansas oklahoma
nebraska and now texas we are not out of
danger
yet for our high hazard fire risk so we
just ask that the community take sincere
caution in your outdoor activities low
visibility from heavy smoke is hampering
firefighters on the ground and in the
air but there is one sign of hope
showers are in the forecast next week
jennifer johnson global news washington
just ahead the cosmic photo op causing a
stir around the world and beyond
all right go for it
all right go ahead go first
russian cosmonauts have arrived at the
international space station but it's
what they're wearing that's getting the
most attention the three men boarded
dressed in yellow spacesuits with blue
accents the colors of ukraine the
standard russian uniform is plain blue
and at least one of the astronauts was
seen wearing it before takeoff
when asked about the decision to wear
the new suits one of the cosmonauts said
they had a lot of yellow material to use
up
four u.s soldiers have been killed in
norway their aircraft crashed during a
nato military exercise there troops
prepared for what's known as the cold
response exercise for two weeks before
the deadly incident a rescue helicopter
and a norwegian military plane found the
wreckage but poor weather conditions
have made it impossible for rescue
aircraft to land
thirty thousand troops from nato and
partner countries are taking part in the
exercises which continue until april
first
for the first time since january of last
year the chinese government is reporting
deaths from cobot 19. in the past day
two people have died from the illness
both were elderly with underlying health
conditions one was not vaccinated the
country's official coveted death toll is
over 4 600. china is now facing its
worst covet outbreak since the virus
emerged in late 2019.
next a hockey historian's goal to see
the game's indigenous origins score a
place in the hall of fame
[Music]
it may be canada's game but a form of
hockey was being played here long before
canada existed now as ross lord reports
one researcher wants to see a first
nation recognized in the hockey hall of
fame for its part in developing the game
as a hockey fan and researcher mark
grant has come to a stark conclusion
indigenous communities that helped
develop canada's national pastime have
been unjustly ignored the contribution
that they have made as craftsman alone
is nothing short of epic and it needs to
be brought to the canadian public's
attention contributions made more clear
to grant after he watched this
documentary called the game of hockey
amigma story compiling both written and
oral histories the documentary
highlights popular hockey sticks made by
migma craftsmen from tree branches in
the 1800s
that helped popularize the game and
wooden pucks that predate the national
hockey league but were the same size as
those that were mass produced later he
said it was an inch thick and three
inches wide
and today the nhl official puck is three
inches wide and one inch thick as i
watched the video i realized
how
many of my pre-existing assumptions
about ice hockey history were in serious
need of reconsideration
as i contemplated what they were telling
me
grant was so taken he sent a submission
to the hockey hall of fame for the migma
to be recognized in the builder category
i would love to see
the hockey hall of fame
induct the mygma first nation
or create a special place for them
within the hall as a permanent exhibit
for the documentary's co-director migma
activist cheryl maloney wider
recognition makes perfect sense i think
the roots of the game are migma roots
and how funny is that with the the roots
of trees i think this would be a really
important move for canada and the game
of hockey
to bring back those stories and
recognize that
this history was lost to canadians not
just the migma people but canadians the
hall of fame currently includes a
diversity exhibit but there's no
specific mention of the mig-mock
contribution to developing the game
submissions that are supported and
eventually approved by the hall's
selection committee are announced in
june ross lord global news windsor nova
scotia
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is this patriotic
and illuminated astronaut sculpted out
of snow in winnipeg manitoba
some light on this last night of winter
thanks for watching hope you'll join us
again tomorrow have a good night
[Music]